[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my wonder woman 1984
video for the post credit scene and the
end of the movie
also talk about how this sort of
dovetails with what's going on with the
justice league snyder cut
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because
it's christmas we're doing an amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
part of the movie on the video
and what you want them to do with her
during wonder woman 3 given all the
extra powers that she had during wonder
woman 1984.
i know there are a lot of questions now
if she can fly in this how come she's
not flying in the present day movies
like batman v superman or justice league
i will address that when we get to that
part of the video but obviously careful
for spoilers from
everything that happens during wonder
woman 1984 because we'll have to talk
about the entire end of the movie not
just the post-credits scene
but just starting at the end wonder
woman realizes that the dreamstone has
taken her power in exchange for granting
her
wish to bring back steve trevor the way
they accomplish that in the movie is
that steve trevor basically inhabits the
body of another character sort of
replacing him in his body when he's
around
anyone that looks at him sees the
original guy like when he looks in a
mirror but wonder woman sees him and
hears him as steve trevor
he convinces her that the lie is not
worth it she needs to save the world and
she can't do that without her powers
so she takes back her wish steve trevor
kind of dies again everyone pressed f in
the chat to pay respects to chris pine
she gets her powers back just as maxwell
lord and cheetah go to a presidential
bunker where he can transmit his power
of the dreamstone to the entire world
so literally everyone all over the
planet will succumb to its power making
wishes
wonder woman full-on flies during the
movie as you can see she can fly in the
comics so we'll see how they explain
this to the justice league snyder cut
version of the movie because in the
theatrical cut in present day
she never flies in any of those movies i
think that's mostly just a director's
choice like they were introducing her
and slowly leveling her
up but if you think about it a little
she's been able to do this this entire
time so it does wind up being a little
bit silly
there'll probably be a couple minor
continuity issues just because of what
they decided to do with her during
wonder woman 1984
but zack snyder did say that she has
some really really badass action scenes
during the justice league snyder cut
that are different from the theatrical
cuts so if you felt like there wasn't
enough action scenes during wonder woman
1984 which is a common complaint
the justice league snyder cup will be
more of a straight up superhero comic
book movie like you would normally
expect
there was a big invisible jet easter egg
here but it's actually her
trying to replicate the powers of her
father zeus to make it invisible the way
he made themyscira invisible
she said earlier she made a coffee cup
invisible but she doesn't remember how
she did it
and because it's invisible she can't
find the coffee cup anymore so it's
actually a pretty
op power that maybe she'll wind up using
in future movies
and during one of her flying scenes
there is a scene directly referencing a
moment
from the end of the first superman movie
when he's flying through the clouds and
you're hearing the voices of jor-el
speak to him about not being able to
change the past the course of human
history before he flies around the world
and spins it backwards reversing time
the wonder woman version of the scene is
when she's flying to the island to stop
maxwell lord and cheetah
and she hears the voices of all the
different people around the world
calling out making their wishes
one of the other bigger easter eggs
early on is that one of the people who
works with maxwell lord
is simon stag he's the business partner
that he gets rid of pretty early on
but she grabs the golden armor of
asteria one of the previous
amazonian heroes who was out in the
world helping people she shows up in a
second
obviously because as part of the
post-credit scene but she uses the armor
to fight the final boss form of
cheetah who's gotten powerful enough to
hurt her even when wonder woman is at
full power
if you haven't seen any of the animated
wonder woman movies there are leveled up
boss versions of cheetah that can
actually claw wonder woman's skin out
like her nails are strong enough to
pierce her skin whereas
normally she can deflect bullets like
it's no big deal canonically wonder
woman isn't quite as strong as superman
but she's like the next closest thing to
being as strong as superman who's
basically god tier powerful
but cheetah has made another wish to
become an apex predator which takes her
to full comic book form cheetah
most of the movie after she makes her
first wish she's just kind of mid-level
powerful but still looks fully human
she effectively wishes to be just like
wonder woman because she admires her so
much she's kind of a wonder woman stan
at the beginning of the movie wonder
woman tries to save her
get her to take back her wish just like
she did like it's not worth it the lie
isn't worth it but she refuses to do it
because of course they're going to have
their full-on boss fight
the special effects were okay and i
think we can all be thankful that they
didn't go full
cats with cheetah we didn't have a cat's
situation this isn't a horror film but
that's also part of the reason why they
did the fight at night to hide the
special effects as much as possible so
that you're not looking too
closely and it comes off a little bit
better there's way more special effects
like this in the justice league snyder
cut for reference
zack snyder did an interview a little
while ago saying that there are more
visual effects shots in the snyder cut
than in
all of avengers end game so we'll see
what that actually ends up looking like
in march when they release all those
episodes
wonder woman doesn't kill cheetah but
she does beat the crap out of her and
eventually she does get her to take
part of her apex predator wish back but
it's unclear if she loses all of her
abilities
because she goes back to looking exactly
like she did when she was still
mid-level powerful funny enough though
she uses maxwell lord using the same
trick
that she used on aquaman in justice lee
they turned the joke from justice league
into a big twist of the movie
she sneaks the lasso of truth under him
while he's busy transmitting to the
world
she uses that to speak to the rest of
the world and show them the truth like
no i'm not talking to you i'm talking to
all of them
everyone's going crazy all over the
world because of the side effects of the
dreamstone
but also as part of this a couple
different nations are getting ready to
fire their nukes so the world is getting
ready to blow itself up in mutually
assured destruction
they reveal during the movie that the
dreamstone was created by the god of
treachery go figure that this is the end
game of that
within the universe the lore behind the
stone is that the cultures that had it
previously
all annihilated themselves and banished
without a trace
so obviously this is what happened to
them they all annihilated themselves
because they succumbed to the dream
stone
she convinces maxwell lord that he's
about to lose his son
and he pulls a wonder woman taking his
wish back reversing most of the damage
that he's done
reuniting with him after a small time
jump i think it's assumed that he and
cheetah don't go to prison at least
right away because maxwell lord is
running around free and clear after this
time jump reuniting with his son
and if wonder woman was gonna haul
anyone to prison if we're talking about
christopher reeve
superman easter eggs because a lot of
this movie does feel like a christopher
reeve superman movie
she'd be taking him to prison just like
superman flies lex luthor to prison at
the end of one of his movies
the world chills out and everyone starts
celebrating all over the place
and then later after another time jump
during christmas wonder woman is walking
around a town square passes the man
whose body steve trevor had temporarily
stolen
he jokes about how his friends make fun
of him for his crazy 80s outfit
you have to remember it is the 1980s
when this movie is happening but it's a
call back to steve trevor
trying all the crazy outfits earlier in
the movie the parachute pants the fanny
packs the members only jacket
does everybody parachute now what's
going on here then after another time
jump she ends the movie flying through
the clouds
like superman the way they visualize her
flying scenes are a little bit
like christopher reeves superman flying
scenes obviously very different from the
way henry cavill's superman flies just
the way they visualize that
but again that's another conscious
design choice by patty jenkins to
reference the christopher reeve superman
she hears a siren in the distance then
flies off to help and that's basically
what she's doing
until present day when the events of
batman v superman and then justice
league pick up
but then during the post-credits scene
somewhere else in an american city after
another time jump a pole
breaks and almost crushes the baby but a
woman in blue stops it like it's no big
deal without breaking her step
and as the woman rushes to thank her for
saving her child she turns around and
it's revealed to be
linda carter in the flesh who's playing
asteria
the person who wonder woman's golden
armor belonged to before her
the amazon before wonder woman who had
gone out into the world to help mankind
she says it's no big deal just a simple
trick of shifting your weight and i've
been doing this
for a long time sort of metaphorically
winking at the camera and it's meant to
be a big reference to linda carter's
wonder woman tv show
like yes asteria has been helping people
in the dc eu
within the continuity of the movie for a
long time because she's ancient like the
other amazons
but also in real life linda carter has
literally been doing the wonder woman
thing
for a long time then they go back to the
credits just implying that asteria
linda carter's character might show up
again during wonder woman 3 or some
other future movie if they want
the whole thing with the linda carter
cameo is that patty jenkins said during
the first movie
she had kind of wanted to do it but it
just didn't work out the way she wanted
to
so when they got to the second movie
when she knew she was going to do wonder
woman 1984
she made a big deal about getting linda
carter in the movie and linda carter
said that she would always be happy to
cameo in one of the wonder woman movies
as long as they wrote a good part for
her so that's why they created the
asteria character in the universe of the
movie
were christopher reeve to still be alive
in present day it sort of be like then
doing a henry cavill superman film
then saying that christopher reeve
superman is just another version of
superman from another earth and he comes
in cameos at the end of one of
superman's movies
like i've been doing this for a long
time and they sort of answered some of
the other big questions people had going
into it like what's going on with
lasswing the lightning bolts she really
is
lassoing the lightning bolt but she's
also full blown flying at the same time
but if you haven't heard about patty
jenkins and gal gadot talk about wonder
woman 3 they did say that that would be
set during present day but they haven't
signed patty jenkins to the movie yet so
they're not making it yet it's just a
theoretical movie at this point and she
said that she wouldn't do
wonder woman 3 until after she does her
star wars movie the rogue squadron movie
which actually is confirmed to be
in the distant future after the events
of the new star wars movies
they released a teaser for that back
during the disney investor meeting so
she'll start talking more about her star
wars movie in the next couple of years
as she starts to make it but that's not
going to premiere till december
2023 so it's still a couple years away
the real future of the star wars
franchise is actually in the disney plus
series there are 10 new star wars shows
coming in the next couple of years i've
been doing a bunch of videos about that
so i'll link them in the description
the whole thing with the justice league
snyder cut is that zack snyder confirmed
that it was going to premiere in march
it's supposed to be i believe
four episodes they're gonna air in four
different parts just because it's going
to be over four hours long
but zack snyder said that he'd be
releasing another really big trailer in
january sometime and they start spinning
up and promoting the movie so we'll
learn more details about that they might
change the release date just a little
bit
but if you have any of the big questions
about the end of the movie or any big
easter egg questions just write them
below in the comments
the next really big thing that's
happening is that the marvel wand
division episodes are going to premiere
january 15th i'll be doing episode
videos for that so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see those when they drop there's also a
bunch of other stuff that's going to be
happening between now and then too
everyone click here for that new star
wars rogue one prequel trailer video
and click here for all my mandalorian
season 3 episodes and season 2 episode
videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe merry christmas
you